- I want to win.
I want to play serious.
I want to be effective.
Maybe because I am a Latin guy,
I need to be close to the guys.
- We had decided that he
will be the next coach
of the first team of Barcelona.
And when I told him this he said that,
'You wouldn't have the balls.'
- He's a Spanish
professional football coach,
former player, and current
manager of Manchester City.
As a manager, he won 14
trophies in the first four years
of his managing career.
He's considered by players,
managers, and commentators
to be one of the best
managers in the world.
He's Pep Guardiola and here's my take
on his top 10 rules to success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite
and I'm curious to figure
out which one you guys like
the best and as always
if Pep says something
that really means something to you
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(opening theme music)
(dramatic music)
- Sophisticated.
- Magical.
- Intense.
- Motivator.
- Calculated.
- Genius.
- Evolutionary.
- Great coach.
- The perfect job.
- Excellent.
- Perfectionist.
- An obsessive.
- Passionate.
- Visionary.
- Pep, Pep is love.
- Talking of talented players
for any young viewers out there
who want to become a
professional footballer,
what one bit of advice
would you have for them?
- [Pep] They have to look inside
to themselves, if they have passion.
That's all.
If they have passion they can do it.
If they play just
because it's always in TV
or it is to be famous,
you can go out with the beautiful girls
or win a lot of money, there is no chance.
Do it, do it and not
just for the football.
Like I think about life.
If you like to do something
then you can spend a thousand
million hours in that
because you love it.
All the professionals
stay a long long time
playing every three
days in important games
because they love the game.
If they don't love the game,
they don't love training,
they can't stay for long.
- It seems to be that mangers
from other countries come
and they are quickly
addicted to the place.
Have you spoke to anybody on that behalf?
- They told me it's so hard, so tough,
and other people say Pep
is not going to adapt
in that he's not cut in that way
so that's why I am here to try to do it.
The people have confidence it's going well
but some of them in Germany
as well the people say
the way you play would
not be possible here
in the Premier League so
and I said myself why not?
Why we don't travel there to try it?
And that's why.
It's a big challenge.
Not just for me but I
am always in my teams,
I was able to boss the players
and it is going to happen here as well.
When that happens everything will be easy.
- You've said you are
obsessive about build-up play.
In order to get results, would
you sacrifice that at all?
- Impossible.
It's impossible.
Sacrifice for what, so you lose the game?
If you believe in that,
you have to keep going.
So, when it's going to happen,
when to use the goal keeper,
you're going to wrong pass
and you're going to receive a goal
and the people say why
you doesn't hit ball,
no you have to insist on that
there is a why, why you miss that pass.
- So you wouldn't, what we call win ugly?
Play maybe not attractive if
you're going to get a win.
- No no no no, I will win.
The people say no is it
when you play the build-up
or you know, I want to win.
I want to play serious.
I want to be effective.
I don't do that to be I want
to play build-up, no no.
I make a build-up to convince the players
that this is a consequence
of positives and negatives.
If I believed and do that
and it is not productive
for the team, I would not do that.
But I was a football player and manager
and always when I do that I
would score a lot of goals
and concede few and that's
why I believe in that.
- So it's attractive but with purpose.
- Of course, I want to win because
if not City's going to fire me.
- [Interviewer] If you
were to win the trophy
again at Wembley, would you feel
you would have come full circle?
- Yeah, but never thought
to play in Barcelona
when I was a boy, never thought
to win Champions League,
never thought to become a coach,
but before to win a championship
and now to try to beat one of
the best teams of the world
in this atmosphere in Wembley,
for us it's a dream come true.
- You say that or we read
that you say that you
only really stay anywhere
for three or four years.
Do you intend to build a legacy
or at least put the foundations...
- No, I came to learn.
- You've come to learn?
- Yeah, of course, that's why I move on.
I came to learn.
You know there will be still in Barcelona.
- What is the biggest
challenge you face now?
What is at the top of your to-do list?
- Play good.
- [Woman] Play good?
- And after try to win one game
and after second one and after another one
but the first target is
team spirit and play good
as much as possible and
after, try to win one game,
and after the second one.
- Three years from now
when you threaten to leave
and we have to tie you to a chair,
and we won't let you leave,
we'll take your passport
off you,
what does success look
like three years from now
for Manchester City?
- Yeah, you know for the
people, for the media,
how many titles are you going to win?
Okay, you have success or not success.
That is pretty sure.
So, but at the end the title
is amazing, you lift the title
and two days after the
people say what's next?
I think the process is how
I will be comfortable here
working with these guys.
At the end my life, it depends on that.
I will be happy when my
relationship with them
and when we decide to play in that way,
it works or it doesn't works
and that is the end.
And I am pretty sure
the club will fantastic
and the people working
with are going to help me.
I'm pretty sure that's going to happen.
It happened in Barcelona,
happened in Bayern Munich,
and it's going to happen here.
And of course, they're
going to fight everyday
to win the titles and
especially form the people
after the game, when
we finish the game so,
'Oh, 90 minutes, it was not bad.
'I would have preferred to
be here and not in the bar.'
That is a good sign, you know.
And after the relationship
with the people.
I think maybe because I am a Latin guy,
I need to be close to the
guys to have to say...
I'm going to kill you and five
minutes to love each other.
I think I need that to be happy.
And I hope in three years
that is going to happen.
- [Joan] We went to a
restaurant in Barcelona
to talk personally.
We had decided that he
would be the next coach
of the first team for Barcelona.
And when I told him this he said that,
'You wouldn't have the balls.'
You know because he comes
from the first division
and at the same time he said,
'Remember, you know
that with me as a coach
'you will win everything.'
And it happened.
(dramatic music)
(speaking foreign language)
We knew that it was was
a very tough decision
but we are taking this
decision with enthusiasm
and with the expectation that
it will be a great decision.
The reality was much more better
than our expectations.
♫ One, two, three, uh!
♫ My baby don't mess around
because she loves me so
♫ and this I know for sure.
♫ But does she really want
to but can't stand to see me
♫ walk out the door.
♫ Don't try to fight the feeling
♫ becuse the thought alone
is killing me right now...
♫ Thank god for mom and dad
for sticking two together
♫ beause we don't know how... UH!
♫ Hey ya.
♫ You think you've got it
♫ Oh, you think you've got it
but got it just don't get it
♫ until there's nothing at all.
♫ We get together,
♫ Oh, we get together
♫ but separate's always better
♫ when there's feelings involved.
♫ If what they say is
'Nothing is forever.'
♫ Then what makes, then
what makes, then what makes
♫ then what makes, what makes,
what makes love the exception
♫ So why you, why you,
♫ why you, why you, why
you are we so in denial
♫ when we know we're not happy here...
♫ You all don't want to hear
me, you just want to dance
♫ Hey ya.
♫ Hey ya, don't want to meet your daddy.
♫ Hey ya, just want you in my Caddy.
♫ Hey ya, don't want to meet yo' mama.
♫ Hey ya, just want to make you cumma.
♫ Hey ya, I'm... I'm...
♫ Hey ya, I'm just being honest.
♫ I'm just being honest.
♫ Hey, alright now,
♫ alright now fellas, yeah!
♫ Now what's cooler than being cool?
♫ Ice cold!
♫ I can't hear you.
♫ I say what's, what's
cooler than being cool?
♫ Ice cold!
♫ Woo... Alright,
alright, alright, alright,
♫ alright, alright, alright, alright,
♫ alright, alright, alright, alright
♫ alright, alright,
♫ Okay, now ladies, yeah!
♫ Now we gon' break this thing
down in just a few seconds.
♫ Now don't have me to break
this thing down for nothing
♫ Now I want to see you all
on your baddest behavior.
♫ Lend me some sugar, I am your neighbor
♫ Uh! Here we go...
♫ Shake it, shake, shake it, shake it.
♫ Shake it, shake it, shake, shake it,
♫ shake it, shake it.
♫ Shake it, shake it
like a Polaroid picture,
♫ shake it, shake it
♫ Shh you got to, shake
it, shh shake it, shake it,
♫ got to shake it, shake it sugar,
♫ shake it like a Polaroid picture.
♫ Now all Beyoncé's and Lucy Liu's
♫ and baby dolls, get on the floor.
♫ Get on the floor.
♫ You know what to do.
♫ You know what to do!
♫ Hey ya.
♫ Hey ya, hey ya.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
David Kezi asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I also would love to know did Pep say
that had the biggest meaning for you.
What struck a chord?
What change are you going to
make in your life or business
after watching this video?
Leave it in the comments,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally want to give a quick
shout out to Stephen Scriber
from scriberlaw.com.
Stephen, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book.
It really really really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.